The truth is, bad empanada did not
originate my docs. He maliciously spread
it everywhere. But my docs originated on
a niche form by this guy's unhinged
viewers.
>> By this guy's unhinged viewers, you
cannot prove that this is his fan base.
You're a [__] idiot. What are you
talking about, [__]
>> I'm not even sure if Auggie knows what a
dog whistle is. He's like, unless
Queenman pulls up Willy's docs and then
says, "I love doxing Willie, it's all
fine."
>> Really a He pulled up Destiny's tweet.
He pulled up Destiny's tweet. He pulled
up Destiny's tweet. This is I I Your
issue. Destin. They're replying to
Destiny. They're replying to [__]
Destiny. They're replying to Destiny's
tweet. Doxing is bad. This bad. We got
to do something about this bad empanada
guy. We got to do something about this
bad empanada guy. And then a day later,
he tries to dox Jtock.
[Music]
Hassan and his c criminal friend dox and
try to ruin my wedding. Uh, he isn't a
criminal.
You're just lying, but whatever. Try to
ruin my wedding. Uh, yeah, you were
insanely [__] reckless. You were
mindn numbingly reckless. Okay. Insanely
[__] reckless. Uh, and you put your
wife in danger, but you're going to try
to cope and say that you didn't because
you're a [__] [__] Bad empanada is
a known doxer and harasser. If you go on
his Twitter account at any time, you
could see him doxing people. He's
probably the most famous for being the
one who claimed he called CPS on Ethan
and Hila. He's constantly encouraged and
defended people doing it. He literally
opened up a CPS merch line because he
thinks it's so funny.
>> Got a hat. I did CPS. CPS
CPS. CPS CPS.
>> Uh hey, you know how often I say your
trans video was bad? It's because that
type of content creates people like
that. What you just saw? Uh, yeah. I
don't care. I'm going to do it for
views. I don't care. I don't care. I
think I'm going to make money on slot
pedo drama and get rich and famous and
then get a model wife, a Russian a
Russian import bride that I'm going to
have sex with every single day. Okay.
>> S logo with the two skulls. Of course,
two skulls not a reference to anything
in particular.
>> He knowingly defames people. In my last
video, I pointed out that Bad Empanada
constantly claims that Lonerbox's dad
was part of a militia group that killed
a bunch of civilians. No evidence for
it. His response is to give the most
forced laugh I've ever heard.
>> And then he just doubles down on
everything he made up.
>> He complains that I called Loner Box
that I said um that Loner Box's dad uh
participated in the Sa Chhatila
massacre, which he absolutely did. By
the way, Loner Box has never disproven
this until he disproves that it's true.
So, I guess I shouldn't be surprised
that when my dogs doc gets found, bada
immediately posted everywhere. Uploads a
video blasting my name, my bride's name,
the address of our wedding all over the
internet. It's also come out that he
swap. You're amplifying this, dude. Why
are you even talking about Oh god, this
guy's so [__] [__]
This guy's so [__] [__]
Holy [__] Okay. All right. otting
people filing fake police reports all
while plugging his
>> fake. No, he's not. I believe he's
filing a real police report. I believe
the reason I I believe he was justified
in the crowd police report. I could be
wrong.
Patreon. So, I figured if he's making
money off of my docs, I should too. So,
thank you for helping me cope. Do you
have a big fat bulky wallet that's worn
and beat slick finder card? It's
literally a different colors vacuum kit.
the vacuum backpack from use code will
2% off your order. Thank you extter for
sponsoring this video. So where were we?
Oh yeah, bad empanada fabricating entire
background stories about me and my wife.
>> A certain slop tuber who does nothing
but make videos in which he attacks pro
Palestinian people and de facto as a
result of that helps to further Israel's
genocide in Gaza has been outed as
having been honeypotted by Israel.
Israel is literally assigning slop
tubers government assigned Israeli
wives.
>> Man, MSAD's really good at their job cuz
me and my girl started dating eight
years ago when
>> eight years ago
wait
eight years ago. What is this? Willie
Mack should spend more time building
arguments instead of just disagreeing
with his opponent without any evidence
as to why they're wrong. I disagree. I
saw it this way is an appeal to emotions
and/or an appeal to ignorance fallacy.
You may think this was a comment under a
recent Willy Mac video, but it was
actually posted 7 years ago under a
Tommy C interview.
>> Stop being such a [__] fat ass and
stop dating an Israeli.
>> Dude, don't bring that into it. She
didn't do anything
>> since then. Whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa. Oh yeah, but obviously
this is a [__] joke. You're taking
this like way seriously. You're [__]
[__] You're [__] [__]
>> Who's still a nobody on YouTube?
>> So the slop tuber in question,
>> he ignores the first part, right? He
ignores the first part about him
attacking pro Palestinian people. Uh Ian
is pro Palestinian. Hassan is uh or
Ethan's pro Palestinian at the very
least. Hassan is uh pro Palestinian.
>> I think Ethan's more pro-Israeli, but
whatever. Uh pro Palestinian. Um who
else? Who else? Pro Palestinian.
Pro Palestinian.
Pro
[Music]
not as much as you'd think, but a lot of
it is pro Palestinian. All right. A lot
of it's pro Palestinian. Okay. A lot of
it.
>> Question is, Willie Mack show. He's
suddenly making pro-Israel content
constantly. Is suddenly making nothing
but videos attacking pro Palestine
people.
>> I covered Assad before all this. It just
turns out a war starting in the Middle
East didn't make him any better at
covering the news. So guess what? I was
able to make more YouTube videos. He
never addresses my actual points. It's
just character assassinations for why I
should be doxed. Madam Banana then doxes
another YouTuber with the justification
that he's a Nazi and that it's for
journalistic.
>> Does he not show the full justification?
Oh man, he doesn't even show the full
clip. I'm not going to pull up the full
clip. You guys are going to have to
trust I I might later. I might later. I
don't want to lose the flow of this
video or whatever. In the full clip, he
says, "Hey, here's my justifications for
this." He's extremely pro- uh Israeli.
He's anti- Palestinian, and he's pro
Ethan Klein, who has doxed people in the
past. He is complicit in doxing. So, I
feel like this these tactics that I'm
about to employ are now okay because he
is pro someone who has used these
tactics and is complicit in it. He
conveniently leaves that argument out.
conveniently leaves out the argument
that Willie is complicit in doxing.
Conveniently. Conveniently leaves that
out. It's almost like he's being like
insanely bad faith.
>> [__] idiot, dude.
>> Interest. And then he says, "That's why
it's important to dox me and my wife cuz
she's Israeli."
>> You're actually allowed to reveal
personal information about people,
especially their real names, if it's
within
>> Oh, does he play the clip? Actually,
maybe I spoke too soon. journalistic
interest. You know, if there is
journalistic reason for doing so and
exposing a clear conflict of interest in
this guy's content and his personal life
is journalistic interest. It's why, for
example, I can tell you that the
YouTuber Zuma historian, a neo-Nazi
history YouTuber, is this guy. I can
tell you this because it is within
journalistic interest to do so. even
though he did not release his
information himself publicly. Just like
how I can tell you that Willie Mack show
is William McConville and um he is
getting name of um the person he's
getting married to.
>> He literally just scrolled down and
showed her full name. I reported the
video and he added this little blur but
it still doesn't cover her name.
>> She is Israeli and she was assigned him
by the Israeli government. They have
>> Does it really matter that you reported
the video? You confirmed the docs.
You're confirming the docs right now.
What? Dude, it still shows her name. It
dude, it still shows her name. It still
shows her. Look, here's her name. Here's
my wife's docs. Here's my wife's docs,
guys. It still shows her name. It still
shows her name. Wow. W dude.
>> Taken down this page. But as you can
see, it is freely available on Google.
They for some reason, as the guy who is
a public figure, decided to just
publicly announce in public his wedding.
>> How is this allowed on YouTube? He does
this thing where he constantly tries to
justify his reason for doxing me. He's
like Ethan docs Denims when he sued
them.
>> This guy has no right to complain about
revealing his real name to be doxing
because Willie Mac Show went on the Age
Free Podcast, which is a podcast that
frequently doxes people. In Ethan's
recent video talking about his uh
lawsuit against three young women, he
included unredacted legal legal filings
that he made that include their real
names and their real locations.
>> That's just how legal filings work.
Here's a Yeah. Okay. Dude,
is that what? Yeah. Is that Dude, ah,
that's still doxing. Is it suddenly not
doxing if it's through [__] legal
means? No, you're taking private
information and assigning it to real
world identity. What the [__] Okay, I
got to [__] open a Google Doc and
start taking notes. Holy [__]
Oh my [__] god.
What a [__] [__] Holy [__]
It seems like he is going into the
reason that he gave with Ethan though.
So I take back my previous criticism.
W dude
a video clip of Ethan Klein doxing a
random Instagram commenter on his show.
Ethan goes through the guy's Instagram,
brings up pictures of his family
members. The
>> commenter commented from their Instagram
account with their full name talking
trash to Ethan and had loads of pictures
of them and their family on it. I didn't
get sued. I didn't comment on your video
with my full name. At the end of the
day, my crimes are marrying a Jew and
going on a podcast. He's non-stop lying
about
>> you. Yeah, you're complicit in doxing is
what his main argument was. But you're
just kind of dis
>> me and my wife saying she was in the
IDF.
>> Critical Shogun, welcome. Will Critical
Shogun, I need to show you this. Okay,
you I need to show you this. All right,
can I show you this? You need to tell me
if this is funny or not. I've been told
my voice sounds effeminate. I've been
told my voice sounds effeminate in this.
Okay, you need to tell me if this is a
good if this is funny. Okay, critical
showun. Willie should spend more time
building sounds instead of just
disagreeing with his opponent without
any evidence as to why they're wrong. I
disagree. I saw it this way is an appeal
to emotions andor an appeal to ignorance
fallacy. You may think this was a
comment under a recent Willy Mac video,
but it was actually posted 7 years ago
under a Tommy C interview.
>> Stop being such a [__] fat ass and
stop dating an Israeli. Dude, don't
bring that into it. She didn't do
anything.
>> Since then, Willie has made over 10
videos targeting pro Palestinian Twitch
streamer Hassanabi. Naturally, this has
sparked speculation. Is Willy Mack
compromised? Does his romantic
connection to the Middle East influence
his journalistic integrity?
>> Yeah, probably.
>> Is that good? Is that funny? Is that
funny? I giggle. I I I I give a little
Does his romantic connection to the
Middle East influences journalistic
integrity?
>> I think it's funny. All right. I think
it's funny. However, many people many
people have been saying I sound gay.
Many people have been saying I sound
gay.
So, you know, it is what it is
ultimately, right? His fans are saying
she murdered babies. He's saying
propagandist should die as he's calling
me a paid propagandist. They're saying
we're valid targets. He posted a photo
of what he thinks is my wife in the IDF,
but they're actually just pictures of
random teenage
>> I wouldn't say gay, but it does sound a
little homo. All right, thanks. age
girls. I asked my wife what this was and
she thinks it's the Israeli Girl Scouts.
So, he's just posting little girls on
Twitter. My wife didn't serve in the
IDF. She came over here at 3 years old.
On top of it, he doesn't even know her
politics on that situation. He's just
being racist. But the worst thing he did
was put being racist.
Also, I've seen this picture. These do
not look like little girls. They look
like adult women as far as I remember.
You always sound gay. start voice
training. Okay, dude. All right. These
these, as far as I remember, these look
like adult women, right?
I don't know. I'm not pulling up the
picture on stream obviously, but
flamboyant. Yeah, thanks Tyrone. Thanks
for the two, buddy.
>> Post the date and address of our wedding
the week before it took place. He does
it multiple times throughout the video
showing an archived page of our site
because we did take it down to try and
hide it. But nope, there it is. The
time, the date, the address.
>> Yale and William McConville are getting
married very soon. Yale, who is uh
Israeli and Israeli government provided
wife.
>> So now our wedding is being messed with
and they are wasting the time of our
venue, the hotel, and two police
stations. It's cost me thousands of
extra dollars in insurance and
potentially closing down the entire
building. And my bride is coming up to
me and asking me if we're about to be
double homicided at her wedding. I'm
like, "No."
Uh, Willie says,
"My bride kept coming up to me and
asking if we would be
double
homicided. Wow. Wow. Would she have
asked that if you didn't spur out on
[__] Twitter and confirm that your
doces were real and confirm that that is
where you would be in three days and
confirm that that is your wife?
Wow. W Willie W. Love to see it. Truly
>> though, baby. These people don't leave
their mom's basement, but she sees the
news. She saw two low-level staffers at
the Israeli embassy get shot and killed.
She's worried. So, I'm being told by the
police that I should go online and see
if there's any direct threats. And I see
a video.
>> Didn't he post the docs again recently?
Uh, yeah. You want me to read out my my
epic script?
I'll read out my epic script just for
you, critical critical showun.
More recently, on the 4th of August,
Willie Mago tweeted out a screenshot of
streamer Hassanabi watching the very
same bad empanata video that would just
weeks prior uh led to his public
meltdown. Willie notably screenshots the
section showing his full legal name.
Yes, Willie posted his own docs on his
public Twitter with 37,000 followers. To
be clear, this isn't to justify Hassan's
watching of the video or Bad Empanad's
publishing of the video. However, at
this point, Willie has spoken about his
dogs publicly on multiple occasions,
confirmed his accuracy himself, and even
given permission for us to post about
it. So, yeah, obviously I'm going to
need to change the script now that he
has [__] posted a [__] video about
this. But yeah, he is a mindn numbing
[__] Holy [__] Jesus Christ.
>> Made by a guy who hates me. Showing all
of my information and giving a
hypothetical where I'm a valid target
because Destiny's a hypocrite.
>> Stevie said anything involving this bad
empanada guy or anyone that supports him
is just
>> What did he just say?
>> Hypothetical where I'm a valid target
because Destiny's a hypocrite. Stevie
said anything involving this bad
empanada guy.
>> Okay, I got to get his full sentence
there. What does he say?
>> I'm like, "No, baby. These people don't
leave their mom's basement, but she sees
the news. She saw two low-level staffers
at the Israeli embassy get shot and
killed. She's worried." So, I'm being
told by the police that I should go
online and see if there's any direct
threats. And I see a video made by a guy
who hates me.
Okay.
showing all of my information and giving
a hypothetical where I'm a valid target
because Destiny's a hypocrite.
>> Stevie,
>> so you don't care that you don't care
that Destiny
You don't care that Destiny reposted it?
You're somehow Hold on. Okay. How many
views did this Okay, hold on.
Hold on. Hold. How many views did this
even have? How many views does this VOD
have? Because this tweet has uh 27,000
views.
Hold on.
Destiny deleted his uh his original
post. It seems
this is like [__] How many views
did this even have? Did Was this even
made into a VOD?
I don't think this was even made into a
VOD.
Is this even in the video?
Ster spent the last year
This is probably like the only thing
referencing it. It was probably cut out
from the video. Maybe
this has 2 and a half thousand views.
This only has 2 and a half thousand
views.
Like
you're complaining about this two and a
half thousand views. This has 200 times
that.
This has 200 times that, bro.
Ah, holy [__]
said anything involving this bad
empanada guy or anyone that supports him
is justifiable. Mo anything is justified
against bad empanada and anyone that
supports him. Let's apply those
standards. Why are we saying this about
bad empanada? Well, it appears to be
because bad empanada doxed Willie Mac's
wife. My full name, my wife's full name,
our wedding location and date. You also
[__] posted about it.
You also posted about it, you dumb [__]
He complains that Quimman left in his
his name and his wife's name
uh while also posting about it and uh on
Twitter. Classic stuff.
Classic stuff. Holy [__] What a
bumbling [__] [__]
Do I even Do I need to pull up the
[__] screenshot?
Surely I do. Surely I need to pull up
the screenshot. Surely I need to pull up
the screenshot for you folks.
Surely I need to pull up the screenshot
for you folks.
What a world we live in. Your full name
is uncensored.
Your full name is uncensored. You posted
this. You posted this.
You posted this, dumb [__] I Holy [__]
Okay,
this is like This is completely [__]
I What am I even supposed to say to
this? What have I
This sucks. This sucks. This sucks,
dude. I'm going [__] crazy. Holy
[__] So, would Destiny be saying that
those who dox people, those who make
calls to violence or illusions to
violence should be fair game? And all of
their supporters, all the personalities
that back them up.
>> He's talking about destiny.
He's not even talking about Willie. He's
talking about Destiny. Well, the chats
that back him up.
>> This is essentially a Destiny snark
community. This guy.
>> What? That wasn't even about Will. Hold
on.
Hold on. Hold on.
>> So, I'm being told by the police that I
should go online and see if there's any
direct threats. And I see a giving a
hypothetical where I'm a valid target.
>> He's talking about destiny.
[Laughter]
He's talking about destiny. He's talking
about destiny.
Dude, you [__] [__] He's talking
Holy [__] I I This is like I Okay.
Okay.
[Music]
Cuz
Destiny's a hypocrite.
>> Stevie said, "Anything involving this
bad empanada guy or anyone that supports
him is justifiable, ammo. Anything is
justified against Bad Empanada and
anyone that supports him." Let's apply
those standards. Why are we saying this
about Bad Empanada? Well, it appears to
be because Bad Empanada doxed Willie
Mac's wife. So, would Destiny be saying
that those who dox people, those who
make calls to violence or illusions to
violence should be fair game? And all of
their supporters, all the person,
>> he's talking about Destiny. He's talking
about Destiny. This is not about [__]
Willy Mack personalities that back him
up. All the chatters that back him up.
>> This is essentially a Destiny snark
community. This guy's narrative for the
past six months is that I'm covering.
>> Okay. I' I've been given a gamma tweet.
Gamma's been activated.
>> Lemon was like,
>> "All right, you being someone who has
been doxed, don't you think it's
reckless to put this out in the public
that X and Y have been doxed? Why are
you complaining about dickers spreading
your docks, though all he did was
address it?"
>> Yeah. And he got doxed and I love that.
You know, I don't think he ever said
that, right,
>> bro? If you're this stupid, make life
better for everybody and just quit.
Destiny has recently doxed J stalking.
>> Dude, Auggie had like a perfect take
there. What are you doing? What the [__]
are you doing,
>> Queman? His motivation behind this is
that everyone they associate with him
ends up getting doxed and harassed.
>> Any point was
>> What the [__] are you doing? What the
[__] are you doing, bro? What the [__]
are you doing?
Oh,
okay.
>> For Destiny, despite me making two of
the most in-depth videos criticizing him
there.
>> Two of the most indepth videos
criticizing him
>> months is that I'm covering for Destiny
despite me making two of the most two of
the most in-depth videos criticizing him
video that I'm making about Willie Mac.
I was going to talk about these videos,
but I didn't have a transition in mind.
This is a perfect transition. Hold on.
W, dude. [__] W. Most in-depth videos
criticizing him. Their evidence behind
this is I said Destiny is better at
covering the news than Hassan and Vosch,
which is somebody who has made videos on
all three of these people. I think
that's objectively true, but I digress.
But most importantly, it's that when
these two do
>> That's not what you said. You respected
him. You said you respected him still.
He's just lying. He's just lying about
the critique.
>> Something stupid. I make fun of them
back. The truth is bad empanada did not
originate my docs. He maliciously spread
it everywhere. But my docs originated on
a niche forum by this guy's unhinged
viewers.
by this guy's unhinged viewers.
Hold on. Let's see what what Kiwi Farm
store this even was.
Uh,
dude, I wasn't even going to mention the
Kiwi Farms thread. I wasn't even going
to mention the Kiwi Farms thread cuz I I
personally
I personally thought that was like too
far.
I wasn't going to mention it.
I wasn't going to mention it because
again, personally, I just don't, you
know,
I have no problem with Kiwi Farms. Uh,
but I don't know. I I can't verify
what's on every single [__] thread,
right? I can't verify what is and isn't
going to be there, and I can't moderate
what is and isn't going to be on the
thread. You want to see what thread he's
talking about being Queen viewers?
Someone someone can Can we get eyes on
this? Stephen Bunnell Destiny
Destiny.gg DGG hold on whose viewers
a quiet tweet. Okay. Yeah, this is the
Willy Mack tweet. Everything Destiny
says here is true. Lol. Oh, this is a
[__] Queen of Vine. [__]
>> So, when I see this CL make fun of them
back. The truth is bad empanada did not
originate my docs. He maliciously spread
it everywhere. But my docs originated on
a niche form by this guy's unhinged
viewers. So when I
What thread is this?
What?
Huh?
Is there even a way I can see? Let me
see if I can find the original poster of
it.
I won't bring up names, okay? Because I
don't want to bring in uninvolved
[__] Kiwi farmers or whatever.
Yeah, apparently every Destiny hater is
a Kiwi Farms or Yeah, a Queenman fan.
Sorry.
I mean, I I could be missing a post that
he's made, but the guy who originally
posted this has not,
you know, posted any proqueen
all content. Okay. Can I control F?
So, he's only made two posts. He's only
made two posts.
the mo the rest of them are um
are like comment replies.
So yeah, saying this guy's a Queenman
fan is like I don't know how you get to
that conclusion. He maybe he may maybe
he is maybe he is.
So he is only he has only posted twice.
The rest of his activity is replies or
like reactions.
Is it fine to show this on stream?
I don't want to risk it. I don't want to
risk it. Some mentally ill BPD [__] and
had any hyperfixation. Okay, cool.
Basic. Cool. Uh yeah. No, this person
does not seem to be a Queenman fan. I
can't find any like proquan posts here.
I don't know. Maybe I'm missing
something. Maybe I'm missing something.
Uh but no, you're you're like completely
and utterly [__]
You cannot prove that this is his fan
base. You're a [__] idiot. What are
you talking about, [__]
Yeah, sure. That's just a coincidence.
Yeah, sure.
>> This is a glorified gossip forum where
people troll and use slurs. People do
docks on it, but it's not what the site
is for.
>> Yeah, he is. All right. Yeah,
>> obviously a dog whistle to [__] with me.
He literally gets a donation that says I
everywhere, but my docs originated on a
niche forum by this guy's unhinged
viewers. So, when I see this clip, it's
obviously a dog whistle to [__] with me.
>> A dog whistle to [__] with you. He
literally gets a donation that says, "I
understand what we must do." Wink wink.
>> Anything is justifiable against Destiny
and the people who support him. No. Is
that not the standard? That's that's
what he's laying out for me here. Now, I
have principles. I have principles. I
don't think it's no bad tactics, only
bad targets. That's not me.
>> As he's literally showing my docs,
>> but is very clearly laying out that
those are the standards that he believes
in. Those are the standards he he wishes
to be enforced. is if you're a doctor.
>> Max,
I got to DM Max.
Wait, where is it?
dog whistle to [__] with me. He
literally gets a donation that says, "I
understand what we must do." Wink wink.
>> Anything is justifiable against destiny
and the people who support him. No. Is
that not the standard? That's that's
what he's laying out for me here. Now, I
have principles. I have principles. I
don't think it's no bad tactics, only
bad targets. That's not me.
>> As he's literally showing my docs,
>> but Destiny is very clearly laying out
that those are the standards that he
believes in. Those are the standards he
he wishes to be enforced. Is if you're a
doxer, if you call for violence,
anything is justifiable against you
supporters.
>> Order taken.
>> Okay, that's not what I'm saying, Max.
Actually, I just explicitly said
otherwise, actually, Max,
>> he's got a [__] eating grin on his face.
He know
>> Yeah, because it's a [__] joke.
Because it's a joke. Because it's a
joke.
Because it's a joke.
Because it's a joke. Is he trying to say
that that Max is the guy who was posting
on KF?
>> Like Howard, dude. He's like, "Okay,
whatever. Whatever. This then gets
retweeted by his friend Jtock who pushed
the exact same narratives about
>> Destiny quite
what are you even saying dude
>> on his face he knows what he's doing.
This thing gets retweeted by his friend
Jto who pushed the exact same narratives
about me. I'm obviously very unhappy
about this. It's affecting my
>> the same narratives
that Destiny's a hypocrite.
What?
They're calling Destiny a hypocrite.
What are you doing? You're [__]
You're [__] dumb as [__] Jtock who
pushed the exact same narratives about
me. I'm obviously very unhappy about
this. It's affecting my real life. But
instead of anyone actually acknowledging
this, justify their actions.
>> Justify what? What are you? This is a
criticism of Destiny, dumb [__]
>> Like, why aren't you mad at Destiny? He
quote tweeted your docs, too.
>> Why aren't you mad at Destiny himself?
>> True
>> is defending my already viral docs
that's already in the hands of all
>> already viral. So why do you care? What?
What? What? What? What?
What? What? Huh?
What?
What,
dude?
I'm losing it.
Wait,
this is nine days ago. Oh, I'm [__]
Jesus. This is like This is so [__]
[__] I am like I'm losing my mind,
dude. I'm actually [__] losing my
mind. I'm losing my [__] mind. then
why do you care?
>> But instead of anyone actually
acknowledging this, they do what Bad
Empanada did and try to hypocrisy hunt
to justify their actions. They're like,
why aren't
>> justify their actions of what? Hypocrisy
hunting. What aren't you mad at Destiny?
He quote tweeted your docs, too.
>> Why aren't you mad at Destiny himself?
>> Destiny is defending my already viral
docs that's already in the hands of all
the people who hate me. We're acting
like context and scale don't matter.
>> Context and scale don't matter. All of
the people that reposted your docs are
significantly smaller than Destiny.
Destiny is the only reason any of these
people know about your docs.
Dude, I'm I What the [__] is he even
talking about? This is so [__] This
guy is actually [__] brain dead. Holy
[__] What? Huh? It was actually kind of
nice to see someone with a big audience
who I've criticized in the past stand up
for me and say this is wrong. But look
at this comment. Willie refuses to
acknowledge the obvious that Destiny is
the biggest proponent in spreading his
docs. No, it was actually bad empanada
who did that.
Hey, how many views?
72K.
72K versus 200,000. More than double.
More than double. More than double. Dumb
[__] More than double. More than double
the views.
More than double the views. Holy [__] I
like this is [__] This is so
[__] mind-numbing.
He doesn't criticize Destiny for not
censoring anything, by the way. This is
so [__] [__]
He will criticize Queenman for not
censoring something that Destiny posted,
but he will not criticize Destiny for
not censoring it. This is like this is
[__] ridiculous. This is ab like this
is [__] insane. This is absolutely
[__] ridiculous.
>> Do you know how time works? They hate
Destiny so much they're ignoring the
very reality we live in. That's what I
don't get at all. Is he perfect?
>> What are you talking about?
>> Spreading his docks.
>> No, we're acting like context and scale
don't matter. It was actually kind of
nice to see someone with a big audience
who I've criticized in the past stand up
for me and say this is wrong. But look
at this comment. Willie refuses to
acknowledge.
>> He wasn't saying it's wrong, by the way.
He just hates bad empanada.
>> The obvious that Destiny is the biggest
proponent in spreading his docks. No, it
was actually bad empanada who did that.
Do you know how time works? They hate
Destiny so much. They're
>> It was not bad empanada.
It was not bad empanada.
It just wasn't like I don't know. Okay,
the only reason people felt comfortable
talking about it publicly is because
Destiny posted about it, right?
Like this is so [__] [__] You're
ignoring the very reality we live in.
That's what I don't get at all. Is he
perfectly fine with his docs being
spread around as long as the person
who's spreading it is condemning it? At
this point, my doc is already spread.
The toothpaste is out of the bottle.
What bothered me most in this moment was
the narrative that I deserve it or that
it's part of
>> What are you So why do you care that
other people were spreading it? So why
do you give a [__] What are you talking
about?
Dude, I might [__] have to rewrite my
entire script to just cover this video
instead because holy [__] this is like
ridiculous.
>> Of some greater Destiny justice. If
Quimman pulled up my docks and only said
bad empanada sucks for this, I wouldn't
care. It's the dog whistle call to
action that's the problem. It's so
obvious. Yet, I'm seeing respected
commentator Auggie call me a hypocrite
because I said doxing is wrong.
>> This is from a month ago. Willie says,
"You should delete this. It's just
doxing and a [__] thing to do to someone
whose worst crime is being annoying on
the internet." So, you have that
situation there. So, there is Twice
replying to Jay- Sock's docs, but then
he got upset about [__] his docs
being shared.
>> Yeah. Holy [__] It's as if context
matters. It's as if me calling out a
tweet that already has 100,000 views
doesn't
>> Destiny had more than that. What?
So, it's okay to like talk about docs as
if they have a lot of views. That's what
he's saying,
Dude. I What the [__] This is like so
[__] [__]
>> Upset says you justice. If Quimman
pulled up my docs and only said bad
empanada sucks for this, I wouldn't
care. It's the dog whistle call to
action that's the problem. It's so
obvious. Yet, I'm seeing respected
commentator Auggie. Call me a hypocrite
because I said doxing is wrong. It's
just doxing and a [__] thing to do to
someone whose worst crime is being
annoying on the internet. So, you have
that situation there. So there is Twice
replying to Jay- Sock's docs, but then
he got upset about [__] his docs
being shared.
>> Yeah, holy [__] It's as if context
matters. It's as if me calling out a
tweet that already has 100,000 views
doesn't add any negative effect. He
pearl clutches and gives this big
performance about my quote tweet.
>> I showed you two times. Here he is doing
it a third time just a few days ago
before I even did this stream. And I
actually had to like tell him I was
like, "Dude, delete this." Right. But on
the same stream, Auggie shows the
uncensored link of JTalk's docs. He also
replied under Jtocks docs on Twitter. So
what are we?
>> No, he replied to you, [__]
>> Tell him. I was like, dude, delete this.
>> He's replying to you,
bro. I
What?
He's He's talking about He's talking
about you. He's covering your tweets.
He's replying to you.
I'm like I'm What? What?
What?
I'm like I'm I'm I'm
at a loss for words. How did he think
this was I'm I'm so [__] baffled,
>> right?
>> But on the same stream, Auggie shows the
uncensored link of Jto's docs. He also
replied under Jto's docs on Twitter. So
what are we talking about? Are we going
to call Auggie a doxer? No, because they
don't actually care about
>> No, you're not a doxer. Nobody's calling
you a [__] doxer.
You're [__] this. He's just being
performative to justify what's happening
to me. Augie,
>> what? Huh?
>> X confused throughout this entire
segment.
>> Literally days after he threw a hissy
fit. Yeah. I mean, it just doesn't
really make any sense to me. It's like,
what the are we talking about? What does
Auggie have against you?
Oh my god, dude. I'm like I'm [__]
Why? Why would Auggie possibly want to
justify your docks, [__]
>> I mean, what are what argument are we
making here? This is just crazy. It
makes no sense.
>> I know why he's confused. It's because
he never plays the original clip that
made me mad in the first place. He just
summarizes as they criticize
Destiny and that's why Willy's mad.
>> Too bothered by That's not the [__]
criticism. That's not the criticism,
dude. I'm [__] I'm losing it.
What is he even mad about?
What the [__] is he even mad about? So,
he's not mad at Destiny for tweeting
about it because he defended him. The
doc was already viral. He's He's somehow
mad that smaller accounts are
What the [__] is this guy even mad
about? I'm so confused. What What is the
issue? What is the problem here then
>> by this? But instead, he was bothered by
some stuff that um Queman and JTO were
saying. And basically what they were
saying was it's kind of hypocritical for
Destiny to get upset at, you know,
Willie Mack for getting docks when he
has a history of doxing people and is
currently right now calling for their
doxes. Right.
>> So he never plays the context and then
acts like the reason I'm mad is because
they called Destiny a hypocrite. Nothing
about my wedding or my bride. How is
that possible? And
>> Destiny had tweeted about that though.
What?
Destiny tweeted about that. Destiny
tweeted about that. Destiny tweeted
about that.
>> I'm [__] dude. Okay, whatever.
>> You're being bad fake. I'm not even sure
if Auggie knows what a dog whistle is.
He's like, "Unless Queman pulls up
Willy's docs and then says, "I love
doxing Willie, it's all fine."
>> Really a He pulled up Destiny's tweet.
He pulled up Destiny's tweet.
This is I I your issue Destiny. They're
replying to Destiny. They're replying to
[__] Destiny. They're replying to
Destiny's tweet.
Bad empanada did not make this as big as
it is. You did. You did, [__]
What are you talking about?
>> Point against it was mainly a point
against Destiny. I don't think at any
point Queen was like,
>> "Yeah, and he got docked. I love that."
You know, I don't think he ever said
that. Right,
>> bro? If you're this stupid, make life
better for everybody and just quit.
Destiny has recently doxed. What the
Okay. What are the comments like
Assan is a Bose like
none of these pe all of these people are
[__] brain rotted morons. Holy [__]
Listen,
you got docks. Oh my god. I'm so sorry.
Like, some of these people didn't even
know what happened. You're amplifying
this even more.
You're amplifying this [__] even more. I
don't think you understand. Like, bro,
okay. Whatever, dude. You're [__]
whatever.
>> Jay stalking Queman. His motivation
behind this is that everyone they
associate with him ends up getting doxed
and harassed. So he's doing it back to
them. The victims I know are Destiny's
girlfriend, Dan Saltman and his family.
Me and my wife Hutch and his family.
Auggie pulls up Destiny's employees
saying she was swatted.
>> I was also swatted.
>> This K these are
why? It's Aerodite tweeting that she was
swatted. There is no burden to not talk
about this. She is confirming it.
Holy [__]
Holy [__] dude.
Okay,
now why would she be saying that she was
also swatted
in a reply to this clip? Is she saying
that Jay- Sock and Queen had some part
in her getting swatted or that their
communities had some part in this? Yes,
obviously. But it's all just a
coincidence to Augie. Augie P.
>> There's no proof of that. There's
literally no proof of that.
Oh, [__] proof of that. What are you
talking about, bro?
Bro. Oh my god. [__]
God, I can't wait for food shops to
react to this video. That's going to be
so epic. That's going to be so epic,
dude.
That's going to be so awesome. Holy
[__] Pulls up another example of a
Destiny viewer saying they're getting
threatening letters sent to their house
and Destiny's like, I don't believe
them, but even if that happened, it's
still not that community's fault. A
couple months ago, cuz I'm a fan of
Destiny in the JSON server, someone in
his community sent a letter to my Wasn't
this disproven by JSTock.
Hold on. I got to DM Jtock. Where
Where's Where's my goat? Where's my
goat? Where's my goat? JTO, where's my
goat, bro?
Holy [__] This is like so [__]
mind-numbing.
Like it it's insane how he can be this
[__] [__]
my home. I've moved since then. Thanks
for telling us by the way. to my house
saying, "I defend destiny because I want
to rape my wife and my patients." I'm
going to put an X to dial on that one.
And even if it did happen, right, who's
responsible for that?
>> What about the guy dog whistling that
I'm a valid target and getting a dono
saying they understand? this. Okay,
again, this isn't them saying you're a
valid target, dumb [__]
This guy is like, "Okay, can I can I see
[__] Queenman's response to this or
like reaction to that [__]
The VOD's going to [__] load.
Is the VOD not going to load?
Did he private it?
And now everyone is supposed to guess
this new reasoning that Willy's going to
come up with in a few weeks. ASOC were
saying and
>> should be fair game and all of their
supporters
>> and all of their supporters. Okay. All
the personalities that back him up, all
the chatters that back him up,
everything
adjust everything against
>> Oh, there it is. The time, the date, the
address.
>> Yale and William McConville are getting
married very soon. Yale who is Israeli
and Israeli government provided wife. So
now our wedding is being messed with and
they are wasting the time of our venue,
the hotel, and two police stations. It's
cost me thousands of extra dollars in
insurance and potentially closing down
the entire building. And my bride is
coming up to me and asking me if we're
about to be double homicided at her
wedding. I'm like, "No, baby. These
people don't leave their mom's
basement." But she sees the news. She
saw two low-level staffers at the
Israeli embassy get shot and killed.
She's worried. So I'm being told by the
police that I should go online and see
if there's any direct threats. And I see
a video made by a guy who hates me
showing all of my information and giving
a hypothetical where I'm a valid target
because Destiny's a hypocrite.
>> Dude said anything involving this.
>> A video made by a guy who hates me.
>> Bad empanada guy or anyone that supports
him is justifiable. Mo anything is
justifiable.
>> Because I pulled up Destiny's tweet.
Because I pulled up Destiny's tweet
against bad empanada and anyone that
supports him. Let's apply those
standards. Why are we saying this about
Bad Empanada? Well, it appears to be
because Bad Empanada doxed Willie Mac's
wife. So, would Destiny be saying that
those who dox people, those who make
calls to violence or illusions to
violence should be fair game? And all of
their supporters, all the personalities
that back him up, all the chatters that
back him up.
>> This is essentially a Destiny snark
community.
>> Wait, he cuts off. Wait, he literally
cuts the clip.
Dude,
there's no way. Surely he shows the next
bit. Surely he doesn't. Dude,
bro, this guy's so dishonest. What a
rat.
Yeah, I mean, okay, let's keep watching.
I want to get through this video.
>> His orders. anything is justifiable
against Destiny and the people who
support him.
>> I don't think creators are responsible
for every one of their unhinged viewers,
but it is not normal for a community
this small to have so much doxing coming
out of it. I've made
it's the Destiny community, you [__]
idiot. It's the Destiny community, you
[__] idiot. It is the Destiny
community doxing people, you [__]
[__]
Okay, as much as Quan and and uh Jtock
and all these people would like to say
they're out of the Destiny orbit,
they're out of the Destiny community,
they still cover Destiny, they still
talk about Destiny, they still uh look
at Destiny stuff, they will talk about
uh Destiny orbiters, they will talk
about whatever. So under the umbrella of
like the Destiny content sphere or
whatever they they will like Queen
covers [__] Arerodite all the time.
All of these things, right?
They are these are not like completely
separate communities. It is Destiny
community. It is Destiny who's justified
doxing. It is Destiny who is okay with
doxing, who's compl with doxing, who is
calling people to dox people. He is
calling for doxing. Destiny is the one
who is calling for [__] doxing.
I I am like holy [__] dude.
There's like no proof that Queman or
Jtock have like any anything to do with
any of these doxing or their
communities, right? But there is proof
that Destiny is like calling for it.
I'm like I Holy [__] dared. I am I am
[__] sub IDF. Oh, did we get raided?
Thank you for the raid. Thank you for
the raid. Whoever raided I'm assuming
Queeman. It's IDF. Thank you. I'm like
I'm like losing my mind. Okay. Yeah, I
did get a I I got clarification from
Jto. I have to censor some stuff if I'm
going to show those. Um
so I'm not going to or on stream. But
yeah, the guy who he's talking about got
like supposedly doxed literally DM'd
Jtock and was like, "Yeah, I'm pretty
sure it's not your community." But then
he got burned by JSTock's community. He
got like made fun of and he left, right?
Like, this is so [__] mind-boggling.
Holy [__] We're only halfway through. I
literally I'm going to have to rewite re
rewite, dude. [__] I'm so mad. I'm
getting a [__] like uh talking
disability. I'm getting a [__]
learning disability. Holy [__] I'm
getting a lisp. It's over. [__] I'm
gonna have to rewrite like most of my
script because all of it is is nullified
by this. What he is saying here is like
significantly worse than anything he did
on Twitter. Holy [__] Videos on
communist, Nazis, misogynist, feminists,
scammers, and traffickers. People with
millions of followers. Yet, this tiny
little community is where all this
doxing takes place. And it's just out of
their hands. Dude, they're obviously
feeding into it. But Auggie knows
nothing. He can't even recite me goofing
on them accurately. Jto has criticized
Destiny for creating a metaphorical rape
machine, partially because he had sex
with BPD girl. Then when these girls
call him out for being abusive, everyone
thinks they're just crazy. JTalk then
had sex with the same BPD girl.
>> Everything Destiny is saying here is
>> what recite me goofing on them
accurately. JTO has criticized Destiny
for creating a metaphorical rape
machine.
>> Dude,
he doesn't even know what the infinite
rape machine is still. He doesn't even
know what the infinite rape machine is
still. This guy doesn't know what the
infinite rate machine is.
It I'm losing it. Dude, to be clear, the
infinite rate machine is like a a
President Sunday hypothetical, right?
This isn't even originated from JTOK, as
far as I understand. It is a President's
Sunday hypothetical where every single
day a girl gets raped by someone but
none of the girls want to come out about
it and none of them is at one point
right all these every single day a girl
gets raped for for infinite amount of
time at one point is it ethical to go
against the consent of the women uh to
talk about this guy raping them in order
to stop the rape machine. That is the
hypothetical, right? That is the
hypothetical.
And like it's so dude I am I am I am
losing my mind
>> because he had sex with BPD girls. Then
when these girls call him out for being
abusive.
>> No, it's because he was he was going
against their consent.
No clip is going to be provided. I'm
sure
>> everyone thinks they're just crazy. JTO
then had sex.
>> No clip is provided. No clip is provided
with the same BPD girl.
>> Everything Destiny
>> again. The infinite rape machine is not
about BPD women. It is about people
breaking consent. How many
non-consentual recordings does Destiny
have to make in order it's in order for
it to be ethical for someone to talk
about it against the woman's consent?
That is the whole point of it. That is
the whole point of that [__]
hypothetical, right?
No clip is provided. By the way, Jtock
does not have an issue with [__] BPD
women.
This is so [__] brainbroken.
This is completely and utterly [__]
brain broken. I am like I'm like losing
my mind.
Let me grab a screenshot of this.
I might need to get a better one, but
for now this is fine on.
Okay. Sorry. I'm like I'm like gathering
screenshots while I'm doing this because
I'm like I'm I'm in DMs with people
trying to um
trying to uh
um how do I change my my text size
text?
Um,
size.
There's a way to like make the text size
smaller, I'm sure. I I can't [__]
find it, though.
I probably can do this in a better way.
Oh, [__] Wrong. Wrong. Oh. [__]
Let me see if I can get like a better
screenshot of those.
Sorry. Sorry, guys. Dead air. Dead air.
Dead air.
That's good.
He's saying here is true. Actually, it's
not true. Actually, everything Destiny
is saying here is complete [__]
Desi says, "And to think that this was
the same guy, Jay- Sock juice, who spent
the last year saying having sex with
mentally ill people equals rape. Crazy,
huh?" No, you [__] That was never the
argument that you have sex with mentally
ill people, that means you're raping
them by default. The argument is that
you don't give a about their consent
because you'll share their images,
videos of them doing all kinds of sexual
stuff. You'll share that with anyone.
>> No, Auggie. JTOK actually specifically
said it's not about sharing images. I
think that the main talking point is
that Destiny distributes people's nudes
and like it's like a weird se I think
that's not the same the the main talking
point. I think one of the big I mean a
massive talking point here is the
infinite rate machine. Okay. How does
the infinite rate machine work? It's a
massive talking point which you'd know
if you were part
Okay. I need to go back to this and grab
uh context
because this could be a joke. This could
be something. I don't know. Uh come back
to this. Grab context.
Is he joking? No clue. No clue. I don't
know. Um
do I DM Jay talk about I feel like I'm
pesting. I feel like I'm being a little
bit of a pest right now.
Okay, I'm like multitasking. I should
not be streaming right now. I'm like
doing 10 things at once. I should not be
streaming. I'm in like [__] I'm in
like [__] video creation mode. I'm
like I'm sorry. Sorry. Sorry. Dead air.
Dead air. Dead air. Dead air. Dead air.
Dead air. It's like a weird se I think
that's not
>> So I need to find this stream. I need to
[__] Okay, there's one other guy I need
to DM. Where's Riyle?
I'm making so many spelling mistakes.
main talking point. I think one of the
big I mean a massive talking point here
is the infinite rate machine. Okay. How
does the infinite rate machine work?
It's a massive talking point which you'd
know if you were part of the if you
watch the Sunday video. This it's not
just about nudes, bro. It's about a
system that let this happen for so long.
And what does
>> that's not Wait, there's no cut context.
That's not even that bad to say.
Wait, hold. Okay, I was assuming he was
going to like cut some insane amount of
context. That's not even that bad to
say.
>> JTO actually specifically said it's not
about
Okay,
>> hold on.
This is so [__] What is his point?
Hold on. We got to go back like even
farther because this is part of a larger
point, right?
Is where all this doxing takes place and
it's just out of their hands. Dude,
they're obviously feeding into it. But
Auggie knows nothing. He can't even
recite me goofing on them accurately.
Jawalk is criticizing.
>> Hey, let me grab this time stamp. Dude,
I'm like stmming. I'm like stmming. You
know when you shake your knee up and
down? You know when you shake your knee
up and down.
I'm doing that right now. I'm [__]
stmming. I'm [__] stmming. I'm I'm
stmming right now. Holy [__] Holy [__]
To it. But Auggie knows nothing. He
can't even recite me goofing on them
accurately. JTO has criticized Destiny
for creating a metaphorical rape machine
partially because he had sex with BPD
girls. Then when these girls call him
out for being abusive, everyone thinks
they're just crazy. Jtock then had sex
with the same BPD girl.
>> Everything Destiny is saying here is
true.
>> So that's never proven. That's never
proven.
He does not justify that with a clip.
>> He does not justify that with a clip.
No clip. No justification. No proof,
nothing. Okay, cool.
>> Actually, it's not true. Actually,
everything Destiny is saying here is
complete [__] Destiny says, "And to
think that this was the same guy, Jay-
Sock juice, who spent the last year
saying having sex with mentally ill
people equals rape. Crazy, huh?" No, you
[__] That was never the argument that
you have sex with mentally ill people,
that means you're raping them by
default. The argument is that you don't
give a about their consent because
you'll share their images, videos of
them doing all kinds of sexual stuff.
You'll share that with anyone.
>> No, Auggie. JTO actually specifically
said it's not about sharing images.
>> I think that the main talking point is
that Destiny distributes people's nudes
and like it's like a weird se I
>> I think that's not the same the the main
talking point. I think one of the big I
mean a massive talking point here is the
infinite rate machine. Okay. How does
the infinite rate machine work? This is
a massive talking point. What you'd know
if you were part of the if you watched
the Sunday video is it's not just about
nudes, bro. It's about a system that let
this happen for so long.
>> And what does Sunday say? Part of the
machine is destiny targeting mentally
ill women.
>> And the victims are also selected either
for mental illness, allowing them to be
easily construed as hysterical or
deceptive when they complain about their
treatment.
>> So when it leaks that JTO is having a
secret relation,
he just cuts that clip short. He just
cuts that clip short.
What else does Sunday say there? I don't
know.
>> Ship with the same BPD girl and she
crashes out on him multiple times. It's
funny. I'm giving him [__] I'm allowed
to talk [__] back to these people. I
talked to Auggie about the same exact
thing a month ago and told him if you
wanted to find it, you could just watch
the ending to my second Destiny video,
but he didn't watch it. He'd rather make
stuff up. Bro, you're sitting at a
computer right now. Feel free to use it.
Auggie ends this hourong segment on me
summarizing that the only reason I'd be
mad is because I'm stupid or because
Destiny controls me, feeding into the
narrative that got me doxed in the first
place.
>> It's hard to like logically understand
why he's posting this [__] I mean, the
two options is literally just he's like
brain dead [__] right now or he's
controlled opposition.
>> Really? That's all you could think of?
Well, let me give you a third.
>> Being controlled by death. Okay, he
doesn't even know what controlled
opposition means.
You literally don't know what controlled
Holy [__] Oh my [__] god. Okay, what
is this? I've been sent a clip. Website
zero is what Keles portrays Kiwi Farms
as. Kiwi Farms in reality is just a
glorified gossip forum where people like
to troll and use slurs. Website zero on
the other hand is a coordinated effort
by users meant to harass their target
not just online but in real life as well
and they have been publicly website
>> w
>> option. Our wedding is having to prepare
for fake bomb threats and my bride is
worried about us and our family
>> fake bomb threats. Is there going to be
any proof of this? Any proof of this?
any proof of this getting shot. Auggie
never once brings this up as a
possibility for why I'm frustrated. It
doesn't cross his mind.
>> Yes, you are a reckless [__] [__]
If you are getting married in 3 days,
you should not be confirming your docs.
Be confirming where you're going to be
in 3 days. That is insane.
That is [__] crazy.
You are such a bafflingly insane [__]
[__]
Holy [__] dude. Oh my god.
Mind. Seriously, if that's the extent of
your analysis, you need to quit. In my
last conversation with Auggie, he told
me a story about how he quit drama for a
year because a guy named Salvo was
doxing and harassing him and his family.
So, where is that same sympathy when
it's happening to me and my wife?
>> Did he say that publicly? Was that ever
a public argument that he was making?
Was that ever a public argument that he
was making?
Okay. I I'm not an Auggie fan, so I
don't know. Is this ever a public
argument?
>> He shares the same empathy meter with
Ian. Hold on.
>> How he quit
your analysis. You need to quit.
Okay. In my last conversation with
Auggie, he told me a story about how he
quit drama for a year because a guy
named Salvo was doxing and harassing him
and his family. So, where is that same
sympathy when it's happening to me and
my wife? He shares the same empathy
meter with Ian.
>> You know, my empathy meter is only maybe
like a quarter of the way filled up.
Most reassuring news I got was when my
wedding planner told me that she talked
to the venue and they told her that the
riff raff doesn't bother them because
they've done celebrity weddings and that
they're in a Jewish neighborhood so
they're used to getting calls like this.
In one sense, very reassuring because it
means our venue wasn't spooked and in
another sense very depressing because it
means people are just calling and
harassing this place because they're in
a Jewish neighborhood. I don't know what
should happen when it comes to Destiny
or Snar community doxing each other and
others. But what I do know is bad
empanada needs to be banned. That stops.
What about destiny? What about destiny?
What are you talking about?
Okay, dude. Destiny is so much worse
than bad empanada.
Destiny constantly does calls to doxing.
Constantly. What is he talking about?
>> Slanders people, doxes people, and
harasses them.
>> Dude, my my knee is [__] vibrating so
fast right now. My knee my little left
knee right now under my desk. It is
[__] shaking so quick right now.
Okay, guys. I'm [__] I'm going crazy.
I'm going to I'm going to do something
crazy. I'm going to do something
unhinged.
>> Recently swatted Kraut by falsely
reporting him to the Austrian police for
hacking his alt Twitter accounts. I
don't think they were ever
>> The way I remembered it, Auggie
disappeared without explanation. Yeah,
that's that's what I was assuming.
That's what I was assuming. Obviously,
I'm going to try to like either get in
contact with Auggie or someone that
would know and see if I can verify.
>> Never hacked at all.
>> He accuses me of hacking. Bad Panada
accuses me of hacking. Specifically, he
accuses me of hacking 15 of his banned
Twitter accounts.
>> His evidence of Crouch hacking him comes
from a tweet where Crouch says he's
archiving his accounts. That's literally
it.
>> This here is the central claim. He
claims, "I got illegal access to 15 of
his 22 temporarily banned ex accounts."
Well, what did I tweet? I tweet, "Yeah,
we managed to get archive files
containing everything bad and empanada
tweeted with 15 of his 22 suspended
accounts." Well, how did we get this? We
went to Wayback Machine and typed in his
accounts.
>> So, obviously,
it's is not you hacking him. He's saying
that that tweet is evidence that he was
hacked.
>> Yes, Vampata actually just uploaded a
video on why he thinks his police report
was justified. And in it,
>> your take on this is entertaining. You
should chill. How many viewers do we
have? [__] 90 viewers, 22 likes. Uh
60 of you have not liked the stream.
[__] donate. Send $5 TTS. Donate to
the stream. I'll sort a goal. Listen,
I'm not I'm not I'm not I'm sorry.
Listen, uh donate now. Donate, likes,
sub. Dono, like the stream, subscribe,
dono, smile, etc. Smile, etc.
>> He just reads his complaint.
>> So, this is probably the most serious
thing that he did in that he publicly
implied that he had hacked my um social
media accounts and obtain private.
>> Yes, you don't need to know how. Smile.
That is obviously an implication
something, right? Is the implication of
that. Is the obvious implication of this
that he went to the [__] way back
machine?
No, I don't even know if the I I don't
even know if I want to say that the
implication here is that he went um is
that he hacked, right? I don't even know
if the implication is that he hacked. Uh
but no, the implication here is not of
way back machine. You could easily come
to the implication that this is like a
hacking or something. Obviously, you
don't need to know smiley face.
Like, yeah, [__] [__] Obviously,
there's an implication there of
something, right?
>> Information about me that is otherwise
inaccessible from doing so and that he
was going to go through it and share it.
>> Hey, no neck. He's talking about the
public tweets you posted. Oh, yeah. This
tweet where Crouch says he's going to
screenshot the unhinged stuff I say.
Yeah, that's evidence he's going to hack
me. Please believe
>> that's not what he said. That's not what
he said. You're actually [__]
[__] You're actually [__] brain
dead. That's not even what he said.
>> Me audience. Like how stupid are
>> is this about the crowd [__] I don't
care about kraut. I'm going to be
honest.
I do not give a [__] about kraut.
Assan supports it. Let's skip to that. I
don't care about crowd. I'm sorry.
>> What's happening?
>> Just like how I can tell you that Willie
Mack show is William McConville and um
he is getting married to a Yale.
>> So he doesn't care. He doesn't care. He
does not care that Destiny looks repost
his docs. Okay. Hey, but he cares that
Hassan doesn't.
Now, I am not going to give you the full
name of um the person he's getting
married to, but I can tell you she is
Israeli and she was assigned to him by
>> Bestis Gibb to be honest.
This is drama slob and banana content.
Yeah, I don't really give a [__] about
this.
>> Like, I appreciate that he stopped
watching immediately, but why are we
acting like it's just slob? I'd argue
it's a bit more ill intended than
it's the name of the video. It's the
name of the video.
It's the name of the [__] video,
[__]
That is the title of the video.
This I
Bro, this is like Oh my god.
What are you talking about?
>> Slap content. Assad is a guy who thinks
the subreddit LSF posting his stream
clips quantifies as stalking and
harassment. If I was a smart person, I
wouldn't be getting ritualistically
humiliated by socially maladjusted
freaks that are agorophobic on a daily
basis in a mass harassment campaign
online. But I do that for a living.
>> But bad empanada posting my personal
info, eh, it's just drama slop. Then he
watches him again a few days later.
>> Empanada is a good good example of this
where I think he's like a crazy person.
Uh he is a chaotic good if that makes
sense.
>> No, it doesn't. Please explain.
>> Like think about how little I
>> Do you not know what chaotic good means?
Have you ever played [__] D and D,
[__]
>> What am I? No, he has not. What am I
saying?
Chaotic good is like essentially like
you do you you have a good end goal but
you do bad things to get there. You're
like [__] I don't know.
>> I I uh think about how little I little
time I spend like [__] on bad
empanada or whatever cuz like I think
he's coming from tactics. We have
different techniques.
>> His tactics are doxing false police
reports, false CPS reports, slandering
people constantly.
>> But uh overall we're working on the same
side. Hassan is literally saying he
supports what bad empanada is doing.
Like Hassan clearly knows at this point
who bad empanada really is. He literally
had a one-on-one conversation with him
where bad empanada said these people
deserve to be harassed. Meaning anyone
Okay, dude. Like,
how is bad empanada worse than destiny?
How is bad empanada worse than destiny?
They're both like on the same [__]
they're they're two sides of the same
coin. They both docks. They both promote
harassment. They both do calls to
doxing, calls to harassment. This is
like ridiculous. This is [__]
>> Who mildly disagrees with them.
>> Be mean to them. If they feel if they
feel bad, if they feel harassed,
honestly,
great. I don't give a them each and
every one of them. We need to be mean to
these guys. We need to be [__] They
deserve it.
>> He knows the guy he's supporting is
doing this and purposely promotes him
anyway. A week passes and they're
talking out about my docs and pedalling
lies about my wife to discredit valid
criticism about them. They're just
trying to assassinate my character.
>> You're just doing uh investigative
journalism. They're saying bada
unearthed that. Is that true?
>> I think bad or one of somebody somebody
unearthed like the the Willie Mac shows
getting married to like a IDF lady or
something which makes sense. He was the
guy who did the the big expose on on
like you with the Ali bombing, hospital
bombing, right?
>> Yeah. Yeah. He's a brilliant political
probably one of the best minds in
politics right now.
>> Truth. So yeah, compromise.
>> Like man, I just keep forgetting you
could justify anything as long as you're
more pro Palestine than the other guy. I
want to end this video.
>> Yeah. The only difference between bad
empanada and destiny is that destiny bad
empanada hasn't, you know, gone against
the consent of women.
Okay. How does he end it off? How does
he end it off with a story? When I was
at my most overwhelmed figuring out all
the new logistics for the wedding, Ethan
Klein actually hit me up and offered to
organize security for it so everyone
could have peace of mind and enjoy the
day. He had no reason to do that. I
don't know Ethan. I've made videos on
him in the past, but he reached out
anyway and lent a hand when he had no
reason to. What got me was a text he
sent me saying, "I got you, bro. Don't
worry, your wedding will be perfect." It
was. So, thank you. Subscribe to the
channel and buy a wallet. Shout out to
the homies over on Patreon. Crimson
Glass, River, Christina, Athena, Danco,
Cobex, Necro Valley, The Confusing
Opinion, Eddie.
>> Like, dude, K, this like this this Okay,
what what pisses me off so [__] bad.
Okay, what pisses me off so [__] bad
is this this hypocritical lens of the
[__] of of Kiwi Farms. You can't say
like, "Oh, Kiwi Farms is just like it's
a troll forum where people just say
slurs and then you know a [__]
whenever it benefits you like Kiwi Farms
is evil. They're organizing my docks
there." It's like, bro, you you can't
have Kiwi Farms is a [__] forum. Kiwi
Farms is not a [__] movement. Kiwi
Farms is not a single person that
decides what to do and what to not do
and all of this [__] [__] Kiwi
Farms is a form and people use that
form. uh just like any other [__]
social media, just like any other forum
site, people are going to use that form
for malicious reasons. Whether that be
doxing, whether that be uh harassment,
whether it be [__] saying slurs like
like this is his his reasoning here is
is so [__] mind-numbing. And then
he's like, "Oh, the person on Kiwi Farms
that posted my docs," which I'm not
going to pull up the thread, obviously.
I don't want to have to go through the
effort of [__] verifying if
everything on that thread is is safe to
pull up or whatever, but I looked at the
account that posted it initially. I'm
like, "Yeah, they did post his his
wedding, you know, uh his wedding uh
website or whatever, but they have two
posts. They have two posts on Kiwi
Farms. They made their account recently
and all of their activity is just
reacting to other posts. They have only
posted twice and none of the posts are
proqueeman. None of the posts are pro
Jtock. None of these posts are anything.
He's just lying about this shit." Right?
And the implicit here, the implied here
is that, oh, people are people are
scared to talk about Kiwi Farms. People
are scared to talk about Kiwi Farms
because people [__] dox you if you
talk about it. So, so the implied here
is that you can't even correct the
record on this [__] because what are you
supposed to do, right? What are you
supposed to do? Oh, well, this Kiwi
Farmer isn't actually a Queenman fan.
There's like no evidence for that or
whatever. Uh, like he he is basically
putting uh the viewer or people critical
of him in a position where they can't
properly criticize him. I'm obviously
going to [__] criticize them. I'll
show screenshots of Kiwi Farms. I don't
give a [__] Right. But like this is
this is such like an implied [__]
[__] where it's like, "Oh, I'm going
to I'm going to bring up some random
Kiwi farmer. That way nobody can say I'm
wrong because Kiwi farmers are [__]
insane. Kiwi farmers are deranged." Even
though they're just like random [__]
people. It's so It's so [__] It's
so like it's so frustratingly upsetting
and annoying that people like this are
just allowed to lie. Allowed to lie. I
know Rich coming for me. I've lied in
the past. Obviously, I'm not going to,
you know, say that I haven't. I've
obviously lied in the past. Okay. Thank
you for becoming a member, Spencer.
But he is blatantly just lying. He's
trying to say that that Queman's
community and Jtock's community and all
of these little characters are a
community of doxers when it is destiny.
Destiny is the person who is advocating
for doxing, who is pushing doxing, who
is saying we need to find these people's
docs, who is repeatedly repeatedly
posting doces.
Like, holy [__] man.
Like, oh my god. It's just so [__]
frustrating.
I'd be scared of Kiwi Farms idiots if
like Willie uh I'd be scared of Kiwi
Farms if idiots like Willie took my
non-conensual audio and then clipped it
from uh for their YouTube video. Yeah.
No. True.
Listen, I'm not I'm never going to be
like against Kiwi Farms. I think forums
like that have a place on the internet
and they deserve to exist, right? Um
like I I'm probably going to be doxed
eventually, right? I see this as someone
who's probably going to be doxed. My
face is probably going to be out there
eventually. It's not now. My address is
probably going to be right.
So like I I I say this as someone who
has a risk of being blatantly lying
about Kiwi Farms to to further this like
[__] gay agenda is so [__]
pathetic.
>> The word you're looking for is
sophistry. What Willie Mack is doing is
sophistry. He's probably too dumb to
even understand that. Okay. Well, I
don't even know what that word is. So,
see use of felicious arguments,
especially with the intention of
deceiving. Yeah, true.
True.
I don't give a [__] about Kiwi, but for
Willie to act like it's horrible and
hardly knows what it is uh and then does
[__] like this is crazy. No, he know he
knows what it is. He knows what it is.
This was two years ago. This was two
years ago. Website zero is what Keles
portrays Kiwi Farms as. Kiwi Farms in
reality is just a glorified gossip forum
where people like to troll and use
slurs. Website zero on the other hand is
a coordinated effort by users meant to
harass their target not just online but
in real life as well. And they have been
public website zero.
>> No, he knows what Kiwi is. He's just
changing his opinion to to to lie and to
try to paint uh people who he doesn't
like as like doxers or like fostering a
doxing community or whatever.
Like this is just [__] brain dead.
And like dude, everything he says in
this video is just like [__] It's
like, oh, I don't care that Destiny
talked about my docs because he was
defending me and he has a big and he it
was already viral at that point. It's
like, no, it's viral because of Destiny,
right? Destiny had the biggest platform
when he posted it. Um,
you you can't and then you're you're mad
that people are hypocrisy hunting. Who
cares?
Like, yes, Destiny saying that doxing is
bad is [__] Especially when a day
later, literally a day later after
posting that, he tries to dox JTO. So,
yes, it is [__] abysmally [__]
for Destiny to post like, "Oh, doxing is
bad. This bad. We got to do something
about this bad empanada guy. We got to
do something about this bad empanada
guy. And then a day later, 24 hours
later, he tries to dox Jtock.
It's like, yeah, you you don't want us
to [__] criticize that. You don't
want us to [__] call that [__]
Like, no. If he posts, if okay, if if
your docs is like published by someone
like Destiny, you cannot expect people
to not talk about it, right? as as much
as that sucks, you know, as much as that
sucks, the moment your your docs is like
out there, it's it's
I mean, personally, how I view it, the
moment I the moment I was okay with
talking about Willy's docs is when he
addressed it, right? If you address your
docs, to me, that's like fair game. It's
like, okay, you've you've confirmed it
as real. We can talk about it.
If you don't want someone to talk about
your docs, then don't talk about it.
Right? If Willie never spoke about his
docs, I probably would never have talked
about it. I probably wouldn't be working
on a [__] video about him.
But he's he's just like one of the most
dishonest [__] lying freaks I've ever
seen on the internet.
This is like I I don't even know if
there's more to say.
Um, I kind of want to end and just go
work on the video to be honest. I don't
know if there's anything. I mean, I
wanted to watch this Mudahar video about
Roblox. Uh, but I think we might just
end.
I'm like I'm full of rage. I got to I
got to work on this [__] Is there
anything else I should cover? How long
we've been live? actually 3 hours.
Um,
I did. I did.
It was not a lolly porn reel. It was a
rape wheel. Okay. It was a [__] rape
wheel. All right, buddy.
It was the rape wheel. Okay.
Rape. Rape wheel. Not lollipop. No, no,
no, no. Lolliporn. Rape wheel. Rape
wheel. Just because you're straight, you
could be. This guy was funny to [__]
with though. Hold on.
Woman, your entire purpose.
Let's spin it. Spin.
[Music]
Do you understand that? Just because you
were born a man, just because you were
born with an I I hate that I did like
troll [__] like this because it's gonna
make people like not take me this.
Granted, this was very funny. Okay, this
was very funny. Okay, this was very
funny.
But a part of me kind of regrets doing
doing the whole troll [__] just because
like kind of, you know, made people not
take me seriously. But, you know, it is
what it is.
All right. Yeah, I'm probably going to
end uh I'm going to go [__] rewrite
my video basically.
Um,
holy [__] Uh, that that was
infuriating. That was infuriating.
Listen,
to be clear, okay, to be clear before I
end, I don't you don't need to um
I don't need someone to be
explicitly anti- Destiny. If you still
like Destiny, that's fine. Just be
honest about him. This like lying about
other communities without any evidence
or any proof.
Uh like even even if Jay-tocking Queen
for whatever reason that you know and
and for some reason I don't know about
this or whatever
is hosting a Twitter space.
Yeah.
Where where is this Twitter? What is he
talking about?
Shut the [__] up. I'm sorry. My phone
was just going there. I'm getting
messages pinged right now. End the
stream. I I won't. Um Ela's ghost, can
you speak, please? Just so I can know
that I'm not completely raped,
please.
Please just make a noise just so I can
hear it like
restart the space.
Wait, can you hear it on your end?
There's no [__] way.
There's no way I am this raped.
>> Can you hear it on your end?
>> What is this guy doing, man?
>> He has he has audio knowledge. He has
knowledge.
Hey, can you get the [__] out of here
with your [__] thumbs down emojis?
>> Hey,
>> morale. How's it going, buddy?
>> I'm My leg's moving up and down real
quick right now. I'm I'm going through
it.
Hello.
Wow. Welcome.
Huh?
>> Moral, are you saying anything?
>> Yeah,
>> I got muted. He muted me. What the [__]
>> I unmuted the space.
>> Hello.
>> Hello. Hello.
>> Okay, I'm back.
>> Hello.
>> Okay.
>> Okay, I'm back.
>> Can you hear me?
>> Dude, I'm
>> What do you mean fix my headphones? My
headphones are doing nothing wrong.
Change your [__] output, [__] Oh
my god, dude.
Okay,
dude. It's over. It's [__] I just
wanted to talk in the epic YouTube
space.
>> Okay. I've just changed my audio input
to my headphones as well.
>> You hear it on Bro, I was talking. You
suck. Can you stop just like screaming
into your headphones, please? Um
A
hear that
>> morale, please.
>> I'm turning noise suppression off. I've
got another person to uh to request to
speak. Okay.
>> Can you not hear morale? Can
I Okay,
I can hear you. I can hear you.
>> Oh, we're cooking with now. How's it
going, moral? I Well, as I said as I
first joined, my leg is moving up and
down really quick. I'm going through it.
I'm really mad.
>> Yeah. Okay. I'm good. That's glad. I'm
I'm glad. I'm glad. I'm happy. Thank
you.
>> You're happy.
>> Thank you. Thank you.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I'm pretty happy. I'm pretty
happy that you're happy. All right.
Okay.
>> I'm pissed.
>> What are your opinions
that guy in a ditch? I want him in a
ditch. I want him in a hole.
>> Proverbial hole. Metaphorical hole.
I'm guessing you've watched it then,
right?
>> Yeah, I took notes. I took notes. I was
stmming. I was stmming.
>> I don't think I've actually seen a Willy
Max show this Max show video this bad
before.
>> He's He just like blatantly lied and
like misused clips. It's like insane.
>> Yeah, it's actually so [__] wretched.
Uh hold on. I am I, as I said at the
like the outset of the stream, okay, I
am desperate, absolutely desperate to uh
to try and get somebody who disagrees.
I'm hoping. Nope. Okay. I said two
people that I was going to let in.
Apparently, nobody disagrees. It's so
[__] annoying.
>> I got no
>> Oh, go ahead. Go ahead. Sorry.
>> No, no, go ahead.
>> Talk about something. You know, you know
when he brings up that clip of that
Discord guy who was like, um, uh, one of
JTO's community members sent a letter to
my house, right?
>> Mhm.
>> So, 6 months prior to that, I'm going to
read this DM out to you. Okay. This is
sent to J-ST directly, a direct DM to
Jtock 6 months before that tweet. He
says, "As much as you hopefully were
joking about our healthcare being in
danger because I'm a nurse, I'm at much
higher risk of being a patient track I'm
at much much higher risk of a patient
tracking me down, especially the actual
psych patients and unhinged family I
deal with uh threaten me to my face.
They know where I work, what I look
like, and my first and last name, which
is in uh incredibly unique. But to
reiterate, I'm like 98% positive that
this wasn't someone from your community.
I just wanted to bring it to your
attention just in case." So, he doesn't
even think it's from Jox's community,
right? And then, right, this was also
sent before he was banned from the
community. Do you want to know why he
was banned from the community?
>> Go ahead.
>> So, I don't know if you can pull this. I
This is like obviously a [__] I'll
send this to you. Um,
>> he got banned.
>> I'm streaming at the same time, so I can
pull it up.
>> Sure. Yeah, you can pull this up. He got
banned for spamming slurs in VC
constantly. He got warned repeatedly for
doing it. Repeatedly. This wasn't a one
time he said a slur once and then he got
kicked off. This is multiple times he
got muted for saying slurs in VC which
is against Discord toos. I think it's
fine to moderate that. He eventually got
banned for this even though he was
repeatedly uh breaking the rules of the
server. So the moment he was banned,
right, is when he started, you know,
kind of freaking out, right? Kind of
kind of being a little upsetty spaghetti
about about the letter. He suddenly
switched his narrative uh to be like,
"Oh, well um
well Jtock [__] Jtock's community is
evil and doxing essentially." Like he's
literally just lying basically
throughout this video. Like his research
is like
>> this is the guy.
>> Yeah, this is the guy.
>> Odishara.
>> Yeah, you can see his Twitter as well. I
can send you the uh the original tweet.
>> Yeah, I'd appreciate that. Cheers.
>> OB This is a clip from um Willy's video
to be
>> Oh [__] Yeah.
I didn't recognize this guy's like
username. I thought he was just like
some Twitter random. Um
Oh, okay. Yeah, it's the exact same
[__] guy.
>> And then I can send you I can send you
the message that was sent to JSTO. I
have to censor. Uh,
>> yes, please.
>> And I I think that if Willie Mack had
like reached out to JT Talk or probably
his like moderation team at any point, I
maybe even like reached out to him for
comment, he would have got all of this
information already, right?
>> Yep. Yep. He would have.
>> So, this is the this is the screenshot
that I was sent by Jtock. This was sent
about 6 months prior to this.
>> Okay. Like as much as you hopefully were
joking about our healthc care being in
danger because I'm a nurse, I'm at a
much higher risk of a patient tracking
me down. Especially the actual psych
patients and unhinged family I deal
with. Threaten me to my face. They know
where I work, what I look like, and my
first and last name, which is incredibly
unique. Great stuff to put up. Yeah.
>> And then the last Yeah, there you go.
>> I'm like 98% positive that it wasn't
somebody from your community. Just
wanted to bring it to your attention.
Okay.
>> Yeah. So, he's he's literally I don't
Okay. To call this a lie, obviously, it
would need to be intentional. So, I'm
I'm using lie loosely, but this is just
like one of the many mistakes he's
gotten in this video. Like, he literally
does not know what he's talking about.
He's calling Queen and Jtox community
like doxing communities despite both of
them uh discouraging doxing when Destiny
is the only one that has encouraged
doxing in his DG offline chat he has um
he has like openly said like we need to
dox [__] JST we need to dox Quean and
then he's openly on Twitter a day a day
after he posts that clip of Willie or
repost that quip uh clip of Willy Mack
right saying like anything's uh
authorized against bad empanada because
he doxed a day after he tries to dox
Jtock
So like calling Quimman or JSTO's
community doxing communities with
literally no [__] evidence and then
saying like I don't know what needs to
happen to Destiny but bad empanada needs
to be banned and it's like dude the only
difference between bad empanada and
Destiny is one of them isn't like an
alleged sex criminal.
>> Yeah. I the worst thing as well is uh is
Max show trying to what subtly claimed
well not so subtly really. He literally
said that that Queman was dog whistling
to his community to like harass J sorry
harass Willie Mack and like what ruin
his wedding
when Queman is just giving commentary on
Destiny's comments about Ben and Panada
and comparing his his standard about Ben
and Panada to Destiny. That was the
entire segment. He doesn't play the
entire thing. He doesn't want to. And
he's also pretending this as though his
issue from the start of all of this has
been about the tweet. It has not been
about the tweet. That has been like
sorry Queean's clip. I mean that has not
been his issue from the start. That's
very recent. That's so far as I can see
this video is when he started mentioning
Quean. That was never his point to begin
with. His point to begin with was about
JT Stalk's retweet and my tweet. But
yeah. Okay. Um, I have got choose a
crusader giving me thumbs downs arguing
with me. How's it going? Hopefully
you've got an argument to give.
How's it going?
>> Um, hello.
Yeah, I mean
>> hello.
>> Hello. Can you hear me?
>> I can hear you.
Yeah. I mean,
>> all right. Yeah, I'm gonna Yeah, I'll
read into dickers or something. I'm
gonna I'm gonna head off.
Smile. Smile emoji, heart emoji, etc.
Smile emoji, heart emoji, etc. Yeah.
Bye.